the biden white house won't answer one
single question about those secret
midnight migrant flights and if that
wasn't enough turns out you the american
taxpayer spending over
340 million bucks to make them oh yeah
former acting dhs secretary chad wolfe
joins us now with his reaction to this
and you know uh chad a recent cbs news
poll showed that 36 percent only 36
percent of americans agree with the
biden administration's immigration
policies you'd think the administration
would see that number and change course
but it doesn't appear that's happening
why
well i think that's a great question
what we've seen for 12 months is a
border in crisis in an administration
that is not offering any new policies to
solve that crisis instead they continue
to double down on a failed strategy uh
that is not upholding the rule of law
that is overwhelming the system which is
why you have these flights in the middle
of night to all communities across the
country
they've broken the system they've broken
the process down on that border and the
result is you're going to have hundreds
of thousands of migrants
whether they are children or single
adults in communities and being released
in communities across this country
because they they don't know what to do
at the border at this point in time
does anyone else besides the white house
think that taking these migrants and
distributing them throughout the country
is a good idea because i talk to both
democrats republicans independents
nobody that i have spoken to thinks
that's a smart idea
well no and if you listen to the white
house or if you listen to the department
of homeland security they will tell you
that they have no other choice than to
do this and that's simply not true there
is another way there is another strategy
to secure that border we did that under
the trump administration there are
policies that you can put in place that
deter the illegal
apprehensions that border patrol is
encountering in historic numbers each
and every month so
there are other solutions we left them a
playbook
when we handed over power in january of
2021
so they do have options and the option
of simply allowing individuals this
catch release and allowing individuals
into communities across this country
should not be the first option and
unfortunately with this administration
that's exactly what they've gone to and
it's what they've been doing for the
past 12 months
they've been doing these flights for 12
months and i'm glad you know now that uh
there's there's some publicity on them
yeah and you know when um jensake was
asked about this she said that you know
this flight took place in august the
footage that we were just showing is old
do you think that these flights are
still happening
340 million dollars is a lot of money
and i think that's one of the reasons
why
the president's poll numbers on this
issue is so low
uh well absolutely they're happening
because uh you just look at the numbers
month after month and then
sorry in december uh over 170 000
illegal apprehensions and the vast
majority of those folks again were being
released into the united states so
absolutely these flights are continuing
each and every day and look to be clear
during the trump administration we also
moved migrants around the country but we
did it for a very different reason we
did that to detain them and to deport
them versus what the bite administration
is doing which is moving them around and
releasing them into the united states so
two very different purposes uh but
absolutely the fights are continuing
before we let you go joe biden is going
to deploy 3 000 troops to eastern europe
in a major show of force is this the
right move sir
well look i i think at the end of the
day uh ukraine is a sovereign nation uh
they are not part of nato so we have to
be very careful about uh you know having
putin drag us into this issue this is an
issue for europe to solve and we need
presidential leadership to push european
leaders to solve this issue without the
u.s committing a vast number of troops
there and unfortunately we don't see
that today uh and we need to make sure
that we keep our eye on the ball china
is the real threat uh and not ukraine uh
at the end of the day that's right chad
wolfe thank you so much for joining us
we so appreciate it thank you hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now